[Musik]
wir können bestätigen dass die
russischen truppen den kampf um den
dollars den sie so lange geplant hatten
begonnen haben aber egal wie viele
truppen sie dorthin schicken wir werden
kämpfen wir werden uns verteidigen und
zwar jeden tag wir werden nichts von der
ukraine aufgeben
ja da sagt der ukrainische präsident
stellen ski und schwört seine landsleute
auf die zweite phase dieses krieges ein
ob der heutige tag den anfang vom
endgültigen scheitern der russischen
streitkräfte in der ukraine markiert
oder im gegenteil die wende zugunsten
putins bringt auch darüber wollen wir
reden in diesem zdf spezial zudem sehr
herzlich begrüße fast acht wochen dauert
dieser unselige waffengang nun schon mit
jeder weiteren drängt sich die frage auf
wie menschenverachtend kann er
eigentlich noch werden welche grenzen
des bis eben noch unvorstellbaren werden
als nächstes überschritten der beginn
der russischen großoffensive im osten
der ukraine lässt jedenfalls schlimmstes
befürchten
die ukrainischen soldaten im osten
bringen sich in stellung denn die
russische armee hat die lange
angekündigte großoffensive im donbass
gestartet es beginnt eine neue phase der
operation in der ost ukraine
ich bin sicher das ist ein sehr
wichtiger moment in der gesamten
operation
ziel der offensive im osten der ukraine
einen landkorridor zur annektierten
halbinsel krim strategisch wichtiger
punkt mario pohl die hafenstadt am
asowschen meer wird schon seit wochen
belagert die humanitären zustände
katastrophal
im fokus dort steht das stahl werks of
style wo sich tausende ukrainische
soldaten ausländische söldner und auch
zivilisten verschanzt haben sollen am
mittag ist es noch heute soll er das
stahlwerke erobert werden inwiefern die
ukraine den russen im kampf um die ost
ukraine etwas entgegensetzen können
hängt auch von den waffenlieferungen aus
dem westen mit diesen lieferung so der
russische verteidigungsminister shaul
würde der westen den einsatz nur
verlängern so die ukraine dazu bringen
bis zum letzten ukraine zu kämpfen
rauchschwaden gibt es auch über lemberg
im westen der ukraine ein ort der bisher
als vergleichsweise sicher galt aber ein
wichtiger umschlagplatz für
waffenlieferungen ist dort so laut
russischen angaben ein waffendepot
getroffen worden seien auch eine
zugstrecke und zivile ziele wurden
getroffen sagen die ukrainischen
behörden
ich glaube nirgendwo in der ukraine ist
es noch sicher als die raketen
eingeschlagen sind bin ich von den
explosionen geweckt worden ich habe mir
sorgen gemacht
[Musik]
präsident selensky überreicht gestern
den vollständig ausgefüllten beitritts
fragebogen an die europäische union und
gibt damit den staffelstab weiter
voraussichtlich im juni entscheidet die
eu ob die ukraine offiziell den status
eines beitrittskandidaten bekommt
ja ein tag der 55 kriegstag gehen wir
jetzt militärisch einordnen wollen mit
brigadegeneral ag erich vater ist uns
aus münchen zugeschaltet zu guten abend
herr vaart guten abend herr kino diese
russische großoffensive die bayer seit
wochen erwartet worden wie gut haben
sich die ukrainischen streitkräfte
eigentlich darauf vorbereiten können
die ukrainischen streitkräfte haben ja
bis dato einen erfolgreichen abwehrkampf
geführt das ist unbestritten sie sind
vor allen dingen infanterie stark also
in den urbanen zentren des landes
konnten sie eigentlich die vorteile des
verteidigers herausspielen sie haben mit
hit and run einsätzen auf die
versorgungslinien nachschublinien der
russen
gekämpft und haben sie unterbrochen und
haben den großen verluste zugeführt aber
jetzt ist eine andere qualität also der
die russen treten doch auf einer breite
von circa 500 kilometern mit starken
mechanisierten kräften an das ist ihre
stärke vor allen dingen in diesem
relativ offenen gelände auswärts ist er
da und man muss davon ausgehen dass sie
den dom bass damit sehr schnell erobern
können die ukrainischen verteidiger
laufen gefahr tatsächlich von den
russischen streitkräften eingeschlossen
zu werden
in diesem raum das heißt da droht jetzt
eine offene feldschlacht bei der die
russen ja auch die zahlenmäßige
überlegenheit ihrer panzer ausspielen
können mit welcher taktik hätten denn
die ukrainischen streitkräfte über eine
überhaupt eine chance den russen die
stirn zu bieten
naja es ist eher die ente guerillataktik
diese hit and run einsetzen diese
flexible
verteidigung in phantastischer kräfte
die sie wirklich sehr gut beherrschen
das ist ihre stärke aber eine offene
panzerschlacht zu führen das wird nicht
laufen ich denke dass die fähigkeit der
ukraine zum gefechte verbundene waffen
auch nicht diesen standard einfach hat
und sie sind gut beraten wenn sie sich
diesen mechanisierten verbänden
jedenfalls in einer offenen
feldschlachten nicht entgegen stellen
sondern eher ihre flexibilität in der
verteidigung aufrechterhalten passend
dazu ein wort vielleicht zu den in
deutschland gerade heftig diskutierten
waffenlieferungen was würde denn der
ukraine jetzt wirklich helfen was
schwere waffen angeht
ich glaube dass schwere waffen ich rede
jetzt von kampfpanzern leopard
schützenpanzer marder das sind die
forderungen auch an deutschland das ist
eine waffen kategorie die oberhalb
dessen liegt was auch unsere verbündeten
vor allen dingen die amerikaner und
briten liefern sie liefern keine moderne
kampfpanzer und schützenpanzer sondern
es ist zielführender tatsächlich über
nato-partner alte sowjetische
waffensysteme zu liefern die die ukraine
auch bedienen können wo wir keine langen
ausbildungszeiten haben wo wir keine
technik mit liefern müssen logistik
instandhaltung ersatzteile all das käme
auf uns zu wenn wir tatsächlich schwere
waffen liefern und die transportfrage
also man darf sich das nicht so
vorstellen als würden 50 bis 100 vw golf
einfach in den osten der ukraine
verschoben und sondern das hat eine
andere qualität natürlich wenn man
deutsche kampfpanzer und schützenpanzer
liefert sie haben auch keine relevanz
für das laufende gefecht und für die
nächsten wochen und monate weil bis sie
tatsächlich zum einsatz kommen vergeht
eben sehr viel zeit und die
ausbildungszeit hat man eben nicht das
ist der schwachpunkt letztlich bei
dieser politisch sicherlich berechtigten
forderungen auch darüber werden im laufe
der sendung noch sprechen so die
einschätzung von brigadegeneral hd er
ich fahre ich danke ihnen für das
gespräch größer nach münchen vielen dank
herr klinner ja wenn also die russische
großoffensive überhaupt gestoppt werden
kann dann eben nur mit schweren waffen
die westliche länder der ukraine zur
verfügung stellen das zeitfenster für
solche lieferungen aber schließt sich
mit jeder stunde das politische berlin
scheint deutlich mehr zeit zu haben dort
diskutiert man seit tagen über die frage
was deutschland liefern müsste und
könnte über die zugesagte finanzielle
militärhilfe hinaus bevor wir darüber
sprechen zeigte florian wer in europa
was an kiew liefert
hier rollt was die ukraine dringend
benötigt waffen munition ausrüstung
dover in delaware usa von hier aus
startet die kriegs fragt zunächst
richtung polen dann von dort richtung
ukraine seit beginn des krieges
unterstützen westliche staaten das land
im abwehrkampf gegen russland hört man
vertretern der nato zu wie unlängst beim
gipfel in brüssel dann wirkt es wie die
größte anstrengung des westens seit
ewigkeiten der eindruck täuscht sagt
einer der die daten ausgewertet hat die
summen die finanzkrisen bereitgestellt
werden ja auch eine euro krise
bereitgestellt wurden oder auch in
corona krise das ist ein hundertfaches
dessen was jetzt für die ukraine
mobilisiert wurde wir reden hier also im
vergleich zu den anderen großen
europäischen krisen der letzten 15 jahre
über wirklich geringe summen und dabei
unterscheiden sich die staaten der
auswertung zufolge nochmals erheblich
mit großem abstand an der spitze die usa
die finanziell mehr leisten als alle
europäischen staaten zusammen erst recht
schaut man sich allein die militärische
unterstützung an
wir reden hier über zwei mal das dreimal
so hohe militärhilfen für die ukraine
als alle anderen 30 länder die wir uns
angeguckt haben zusammengenommen also
ohne die usa stünden keine praktisch
blank da auffallend auch die große
unterstützung aus osteuropa tschechien
etwa lieferte zuletzt als erstes
nato-land auch panzer in die ukraine
heute dazu die ankündigung des
niederländischen premierminister
ich habe den ukrainischen präsidenten
heute gesagt dass wir jetzt auch
schweres gerät und militärgüter an die
ukraine liefern werden am ukraine ein
schritt bei dem andere wie deutschland
zögern aus sorge in den krieg gezogen zu
werden und weil solche panzer ohne
ausbildung kaum zu bedienen sein
ja man sieht europa leistet relativ
wenig militärische unterstützung
jedenfalls im vergleich zu den usa
florian hand in brüssel auch eu
kommissionschef ursula von der leyen
ratschef michelle haben ja an der
telefonschalte mit us präsident biden
und anderen staats und regierungschefs
teilgenommen haben denn diese eu spitzen
zur anschließend über mögliche
ergebnisse informiert bisher noch nicht
es gibt keine pressekonferenz oder ein
ähnliches statement das einzige was sie
bisher haben ist ein tweet der eu
kommissionspräsident sind ursula von der
leyen die vor wenigen minuten schrieb
auf twitter dass man gemeinsam die
sanktionen gegen russland verschärfen
werde und andererseits die militärische
und finanzielle unterstützung für die
ukraine erhöhen werde außerdem stehe man
gemeinsam an der seite der ukraine das
ist also noch bisher eher dünn was
brüssel nach dieser video konferenz zu
bieten hat ich gehe davon aus dass sich
das in den nächsten stunden auch
spätestens bis morgen sich erinnern wird
der kanzler hat ja vorhin eine
pressekonferenz gegeben und verweist
darauf dass sich waffenlieferungen aus
bundeswehrbeständen ja weitgehend
erschöpft hätten man müsse jetzt über
die industrie lieferungen ermöglichen
wie kommt denn diese auch heute ja kaum
veränderte deutsche haltung bei den
europäischen partnern an ja in der tat
ist die haltung ja kaum verändert und
deshalb ist der unmut der ist weiterhin
groß in den letzten tagen und wochen
bereits hat sich dieser unmut angestaut
wir haben hier verschiedentlich minister
und staats und regierungschefinnen und
chefs aus osteuropa erlebt die bei
verschiedenen anlässen bei eu und nato
treffen sich massiv über die deutsche
zurückhaltung beklagt haben beschwert
haben dieses land tour nicht das wozu es
in der lage sei das haben hier
verschiedene politiker aus dem baltikum
aus baltischen staaten oder aus polen
etwa gesagt andererseits muss man auch
sagen es gibt genauso auch länder die
sich da ein klein wenig in deutschland
verstecken die eigentlich dankbar sind
dass deutschland diesen ganzen verdruss
abbekommt aber selbst ähnlich ticken und
ähnliche haltung haben also auch nicht
schweres gerät schwere panzer liefern
wollen insofern das bild muss man sagen
fällt gemischt aus und öffentlichen
wahrnehmung sind vor allem die besonders
lautstark zu vernehmen die hier
deutschland massiv kritisieren aber es
gibt eben auch die andere seite von
ländern die ähnlich wenig liefern wie
deutschland was könnte abschließende
frage was müsste denn die
bundesregierung tun um diesen der doch
ramponierten ruf gerade bei den
europäischen partnern aber auch jenseits
des atlantiks zu reparieren
ich würde sagen es gibt ja noch andere
felder als die rein militärische
unterstützung wenn deutschland also sagt
es sei nicht in der lage ist wollen
nichts militärisch schweres gerät
liefern dann müsste man sich anschauen
was es auf anderen gebieten tun kann und
da kann es ja durchaus einiges tun also
etwa wenn man sich anschaut die
militärisch die wirtschaftliche hilfe
die finanzielle unterstützung für die
ukraine da ist sicherlich noch spielraum
nach oben und dann rückt ganz besonders
ein element in den fokus das ist der
bereich der energie nämlich die frage ob
man hier ein energie embargo gegen
russland verhängen soll das problem ist
auch hier steht deutschland ja auf der
bremse und sagt ein gas embargo das
komme für die bundesregierung nicht
infrage weil weiterhin man davon ausgeht
dass der schaden eines solchen energie
embargos für das eigene land größer sei
als der den es in russland anzurichten
vermöge insofern wird sich auch an
dieser haltung vermutlich in den
nächsten tagen nichts ändern
und insofern wird deutschland auch hier
weiterhin im zielfeld der kritik stehen
bleiben eine debatte die sich auch mit
dem heutigen auftritt des bundeskanzlers
auch mit der telefonschalte nicht
erschöpft haben dürfte und jetzt
vermutlich noch drängender wird florian
danke für diese ersten eindrücke und
auch einschätzungen live aus brüssel
ja wird die ukraine die russische
großoffensive zurückdrängen können die
frage kann zum jetzigen zeitpunkt wohl
niemand beantworten aber eines ist
erschüttern klar dass dieser
angriffskrieg russlands nun noch
grausamer noch brutaler wird ohne dass
die zivilbevölkerung dem grauen
entkommen könnte ein ende des schreckens
jedenfalls scheint am heutigen tag weit
entfernt das war unser zdf spezial danke
für ihr interesse und auf wiedersehen
[Musik]